we begin with developments in gaza where
at least eight palestinians have died in
the latest israeli strike on the
territory that's despite reports a
ceasefire between israel and the
palestinian islamic jihad is imminent an
egyptian delegation is now in the gaza
trying to negotiate its officials say
both sides have agreed to a truce but
there's been no firm confirmation of
that from either the palestinians or the
israelis earlier islamic jihad fighters
launched a barrage of around 100
missiles towards southern israel in
response to the killing by israel of one
of its leaders palestinian prime
minister mohammad shatiya has condemned
the israeli strikes and is calling on
the u.n security council to intervene
we call on this institution to take more
steps than just verbal denunciations we
call for an end to the double standards
and dealing with the question of human
rights and international conflicts
we can never accept the continued crimes
against our people our children women
and civilians families that have lost
their children and children that have
lost their parents and families that
have been deprived of their homes
and a few hours ago more than 1700
ultra-nationalist israelis added to the
tensions by entering the al-aqsa mosque
compound in occupied east jerusalem on
their annual fasting day
we have two correspondents covering the
latest developments the name is in west
jerusalem but first let's go over to
suffolk
he joins us from gaza so a report
suffered of fresh casualties tell us
what happened in the latest israeli
airstrike
well the israelis carried out three
different attacks on three different
locations one at the cemetery or at a
cemetery in jabalia refugee camp
killing five children according to the
sources in jabalia there was another
also attack in gaza city as there was a
raid on a car three people killed in
this uh another attack and now just few
minutes ago
our sources in the central area of gaza
just told us that one of the raids hit a
house in
a ref in al-buraj refugee camp in the
central area a father and his two sons
or two children killed in this attack
which raised the number of this people
to uh
42 including
13 children so
the minister of health says that more
than 250 people injured in the
during the last three days of israel
escalation in gaza
and software
there have been
these reports about a ceasefire bring us
up to date with what's actually been
confirmed about him
well uh yes it's uh the egyptian sources
have been talking about uh reaching a
ceasefire between uh
islamic jihad and israel but neither
islamic jihad nor the israelis confirmed
such report and underground we can't see
the the rockets now are flying or
launched from gaza towards israel so
underground there is nothing actually
achieved and the rockets
from gaza have been
launched towards israel on the other
hand the israeli raids are also continue
to attack different places symmetry
houses guard empty uh fields
agricultural areas etc so we on the
field or in the field the attacks uh
and that launching the rockets and the
israeli rays are continue
thanks so much suffolk
from gaza let's continue this now with
natasha rename she's in west jerusalem
with more on this so first of all what
are we hearing about the cease-fire
well less than an hour ago israeli media
was right widely reporting that a
ceasefire would go into effect at 8 00
p.m local 8 pm local has come and gone
and that headline has actually receded
into the background i want to pick up on
something that my colleague suffolk just
mentioned which is this uh air strike or
attack of some sort at a cemetery in
jabalia according to the israeli media
we do not have confirmation yet from the
israeli military we're waiting for them
to get back to us but again according to
israeli media they are saying that the
five children killed in the cemetery in
jabalia was the result of an errant
rocket by islamic jihad it's worth
noting that on saturday evening five
people were killed in jabalia refugee
camp four of them children the other one
an elderly woman and the israeli
military said that was also the result
of an errant rocket by islamic jihad
earlier today they released video that
they say proves that in any event it's
unclear if this is just the final uh
back and forth before a ceasefire goes
into effect or if we're headed into uh
many more hours of conflict between the
two sides but late today the interim
prime minister yair lapid met with
regional authorities and military
officials in a southern city near the
border with gaza and said that the goals
of this operation dubbed operation
breaking dawn have been achieved and
that there was no need to continue there
had been signals throughout the day that
the israeli government was not
interested in a protracted operation in
gaza the thinking was that most if not
all of the senior leadership of islamic
jihad had been eliminated and that a
kind of divide had been created between
islamic jihad and hamas with hamas
remaining on the sidelines the concern
of course is that the longer that this
operation goes on the higher the death
toll which we've seen in an hour has
gone up considerably the greater the
likelihood that hamas may intervene but
all along lapid has said that this
operation was to thwart an attack on
israel by islamic jihad that they were
only targeting islamic jihad and that
they hoped that they would quote act
responsibly to mitigate civilian
casualties israel no doubt as a result
of the increased death toll we've just
seen again five of them being children
will face even more pressure to halt the
air strikes and make sure that food fuel
and humanitarian aid can get into gaza
all right thanks so much natasha there
from west jerusalem let's bring in now
family abu sharman he is the head of the
gaza office for the uk charity human
appeal good to have you with us first of
all
my colleague there mentioned about the
need to get food and fuel into gaza tell
us about how desperate and already
difficult situation aid situation
in gaza is now becoming
well the situation in gaza is difficult
even before this crisis
gaza suffers from chronic
chronic crisis situations for years and
years
the situation by this crisis get
magnified
electricity cut off
is intensifying like we have electricity
for four hours this puts
a threat on
all the community here in gaza
especially vulnerable communities
health services are interrupted it can
stop by at any time
water water
[Music]
the excess water either portable water
to
the people or domestic
water from domestic use is also as
is at a great threat
continuity or sustainability of health
services at hospitals and health centers
is also
can stop at any time
which
at the end of the day
may would
put more risk on the lives of people
especially
children the situation here in gaza
we as a humanitarian uk-based
organization
we describe the situation as
very serious
it is very serious
we see that
more than half of the casualties are
children
let me jump in there and ask we know we
know that the fuel shipments were halted
when
when israel launched the strikes on
friday
how long have hospitals got before
they don't have power how long do
schools have
they don't they don't have power so
they don't have power the medication and
medical disposable is about about to
bleed deplete
they are about to reach the near stock
levels
which affects the lives of people in
gaza
also
the educational process
is also about to be affected as we are
approaching the news holistic year by
the end of this month
so if things get worse and and shelters
will be open
in schools
this puts more pressure on people the
psychological situation of people
especially children
is is
is threatening as well
uh
tell us a little bit if you could
i'm also curious to know the challenges
and risks that aid workers like you
enduring face
just trying to get out most people are
trying to stay off the streets in gaza
but aid workers ambulances you have to
get out there tell us a little bit about
the personal risk that aid workers have
to endure
well risk risk is everywhere
in gaza there is no safe place at all
a humanitarian humanitarian workers
face a greater greater threat
as they are subjected to
they have they have to to move to
deliver services to affected affected
families affected people so it's much
more dangerous on the streets are you
not afraid for your personal safety
well we
take into consideration all the safety
risks and issues but at the end of the
day we have to serve humans we are at
the end of the humanitarian uk
organization we have to serve people
so
it's it's very risky very risky but at
the end of the day we cannot leave
people
dying we cannot leave these people like
suffering and need assistance and we
cannot
deliver it to them
we are now human appeal uk has launched
an appeal
on the first day on friday we are about
to
we started the the process of fuel
delivery to hospitals we will also
distribute food
to
affected families
very very soon
and we will be also doing some
inter-urgent interventions like non-food
uh non-food items
sheltering for for affected affected
families and the situation is is very
threatening a very difficult situation
no doubt thank you so much for
talking to us about it appreciate your
time
thank you